6 44 on a friday morning ghosts spirits
whatever you like to call them
paranormal investigators say las vegas
southern nevada it's a hotbed for
hauntings the ghost hunting team at
paranormal voyages gave me an inside
look at their methods
and what they have seen across the state
nevada has a very high level of
paranormal activity the silver state
story is rich in history and misfortunes
starting with minors and continuing with
mobsters
i did tall tales or a peek into the past
cash register and everything that was on
the table just fly off the table the
crown and anchor pub off tropicana just
one of the places paranormal
investigators cilia ramos and jonathan
eisenhower have explored we also
investigated madame tussauds on the las
vegas strip say something out loud yell
it
they say they've seen heard and even
felt spirits i feel like i have somebody
like squeezing me the goldfield hotel
known as one of the most haunted places
in the state perhaps even the nation it
really took a toll on me energy
physically infrared cameras digital
recorders emf detectors just some of the
tools they have in their arsenal to
detect paranormal activity so why always
at night the reason we do this is to cut
out any type of contamination from
outside but don't worry not everything
is spooky the team at paranormal voyages
just finished investigating the belmont
courthouse in nye county either one of
you here
for the most part it was all positive
and it's not always just buildings with
a story sometimes it's objects like
their doll lucy we would hear tapping
coming from inside of the box so much as
negative but maybe mischievous in some
way ramos and eisenhower say it all
started out as a curiosity to see if
ghosts were real an answer they believe
they have
after watching that how can you not have
that answer too right so the full
investigation into the belmont
courthouse that's going to air on their
youtube channel halloween night and by
the way ramos told me they do a lot of
residential homes in the area and
there's a lot of activity especially in
some of those newer developments just
what you want to find out hey honey we
just moved into a new house let's see if
it's haunted oh it is great and then
what do you do land value all right
[Laughter]
there's spooky yeah there's so many
ghost towns in the gold field tonopah
area the mitzpa i'm telling you you
might get visited sherry in the middle
of the night by a
lady of the night
in the night so they say so
i don't like i don't like scary things
like that guys i don't at all